-So how many bakers are left?
-Er, nine.
But we had nine last week?
Yeah. Well, we would have had
nine last week
except one of the bakers was sick,
but he's now returned,
so we're back up to nine.
But we send someone home every week,
so that would take us down to seven,
and with a baker coming back,
that would be eight.
Yeah, except Paul and Prue
went rogue last week
and they didn't send anybody home.
So, will there be eight, next week?
No, no. 'Cause we're sending
two people home, er, this week
and two from nine is seven.
-So are you clear?
-Yeah.
[Sandi] This week...
[Briony] Right, here we go.
-...things get spicy.
-Smells really good.
[Sandi] It's a sticky
signature challenge...
[Ruby] Why does he look wonky?
[Sandi]
...a doubly exotic technical...
Oh, my goodness me. They've melted.
[Sandi] ...and the showstopper
leaves everyone hanging...
It's going to be really tight.
[Sandi] ...as two bakers...
[Terry] Oh! Come on. Come on.
Come on. Come on.
[Sandi] ...are set to leave...
-[Manon] Oh, God. I'm shaking.
-[Jon groans]
-Whoo-oo.
-[Ruby] Crack on.
-Unbelievable.
How did I do that?
[theme music playing]
[speaking in French] Cette semaine
c'est la semaine des epices.
[in English]
I'm just excited about spice week.
[Terry] Last week I was not well at all,
so, to come back today,
it's a lovely feeling
and whatever happens,
at least I'll stay or go on merit
rather than on something
out of the ordinary.
[Ruby] Two people go this week,
which is on everyone's mind.
So, the odds are high.
If I were a cat I was maybe down,
to maybe, four lives, maybe less.
I just don't know. Maybe three
and we'll see how
these three challenges go. [chuckles]
[Sandi] Hello, bakers.
[Noel] For your
signature challenge today,
Paul and Prue would love you
to make a ginger cake.
[Sandi] Your ginger cake
can be made
using any form of ginger that you choose.
Fresh, dried, stem, syrup.
You can use complimentary flavours--
But ginger must be the dominant flavour.
-You knew that?
-I did know that.
Yep. Your ginger cake needs to be
a suitable size for a family teatime.
I didn't know that.
You have two hours
to make your ginger cake.
-On your marks...
-Get set...
[Sandi] Bake!
Ginger is my favourite spice
and we're looking for a ginger cake.
It's about finding that balance of heat,
spice, flavour, warmth.
I mean if you want a sort of fudgy,
sticky kind of cake,
then stem ginger would be good.
It's a mistake to think that the answer
is to use fresh ginger.
If ginger stays in the oven
for a very long time,
it loses its flavour.
Ginger does compliment well
with a lime or a lemon,
but you've gotta find those levels
where ginger is still that gorgeous
flavour that comes pouring through.
[Paul] Good morning.
[Briony] Hello.
-Hello, Briony.
-Hello.
-What's going on here then?
-Right, so...
I am making a honey
and apricot ginger cake.
-[Prue] Okay.
-Is it a particular honey?
-Bee honey.
-It's honey from bees.
Wow, there is nothing
you don't know, is there Paul?
[all laugh]
[Noel] Briony's honey and ginger sponges
will be decorated
with dark chocolate ganache and honeycomb
and filled with an apricot jam.
-Where's the ginger?
-[Briony] There's fresh ginger
and ground ginger in the sponge.
Gonna have honey buttercream icing.
-Any ginger in there?
-Erm, no.
-Have you got any ginger in the apricot?
-No, I haven't.
-She's just got ginger in the cake.
-[Briony] Oh, have I missed a trick here?
-Good luck, Briony.
-[Briony] Cheers. Thank you.
I think Paul was a bit worried that
there wasn't quite enough ginger maybe.
But, you know, there's ginger in the cake.
[Sandi] The foundation of
a deliciously sticky ginger cake
is a liquid mix of fats,
sugars and syrups.
[splutters]
-[Karen] Excuse you.
-[chuckles]
[Karen] I didn't like to say anything.
[Briony] Bit nervous.
[laughs]
[Manon] Basically it's gonna
give this, like, gooey...
Gooeyness of the ginger cake.
[Noel] But unless the mix
is warmed gently...
Okay.
...the milk and eggs will split...
[Dan] Oh, God. Just melt.
...and the batter will be ruined before
the ginger has even been introduced.
[Dan] Butter, treacle, golden syrup.
Eggs are about to go in
and something else.
Milk. Milk.
I knew there was something else.
So it's just like the sort of sticky,
heavy ginger cakes
like my mother used to make for me
when I was a kid.
[Sandi] Dan's recreating his mum's recipe
four times for a towering ginger cake
filled with lemon Swiss meringue
buttercream.
Come on.
I'm just trying to get my cakes
in the oven as quickly as possible.
They're gonna be quite deep
and they're gonna need as long to cool
as possible before I start assembling.
These cakes will probably
end up in the freezer.
-[chuckles]
-[indistinct chatter]
[Noel] Now, the wet ingredients need
to be carefully combined with the dry...
Quite a strong ginger taste I would say.
...and whilst all of the bakers
are adding ground ginger...
Nobody's gonna say
they can't get my... Ginger.
...to guarantee the dominant ginger kick
the judges are looking for...
I'm getting my chopper out.
...some are going further.
[Kim-Joy] I am using crystallised ginger.
[Jon] I'm putting in stem ginger.
I love the ginger flavour,
so I always just keep adding
more and more all the time.
[Prue] What is the ginger in the cake?
Dry ginger as well as
chopped stem ginger.
When I tell my mum,
I mean she was quite surprised
at why people
would have ginger in a cake
because in India
we normally use ginger for savoury things.
We cook curries and stuff with it.
So she was quite surprised.
[Noel] Rahul's mum has never tried
his triple-layered ginger and caramel cake
with cinder toffee,
inspired by a very British tradition.
The first time I had ginger cake
is during a bonfire night celebration.
Did you like it
the first time you tried it?
Yeah. I didn't really think
these flavours can actually work
because in India sweet things
means extremely sweet.
So, this is like a learning curve for me.
So I'm learning.
-Thank you.
-[Rahul] Thank you. Cheers.
[Sandi] Rahul's not the only baker
hoping for fireworks in spice week.
[Karen] When I was a kid, Bonfire Night
was a big annual gathering
and all the neighbours brought something.
Ginger cake being one of them or parkin.
[Sandi] Karen's updating a traditional
Yorkshire parkin
with crystallised ginger and cinder toffee
and to warm everyone up on Bonfire Night,
there's brandy in the sponge
and the cream cheese frosting.
[Noel] You know
who's gonna like brandy, don't you?
-Prue.
-Prue. Yeah. She loves a bit of brandy.
-In the bag then.
-She's got a hip flask.
I have to keep it topped up.
[chuckles] Is that your job?
Your little job.
Yeah. It's a big job as well. [laughing]
[Noel] Prue and Karen
won't be drinking alone.
[Ruby] Even in general case,
I love putting rum into the cake batter.
It just tastes so good.
Why bother baking
if you can't make it boozy?
[Noel] Ruby's adults only
Jamaica ginger cake
will have even more rum
in her piped cream decoration,
but the booze should all be balanced
with a triple-hit of ginger.
I've got some stem ginger,
and I've got ground ginger going in there,
and then I'm using the stem
ginger syrup to drench it as well.
So, after all that if it still
doesn't taste of ginger, I give up.
[Sandi] For her ginger cake batter...
[Manon] Ow.
I got some ginger in my eye. [giggles]
...Manon's taking a fresh approach.
It smells really good.
I use ginger when I cook Asian food,
and I've always used the fresh one.
You just really have
the essence of the ginger.
[Sandi] Manon's sponge will be coated in
a lemon and ginger
Italian meringue buttercream
and there's fresh ginger
in her lemon curd filling,
as well as her sponge batter.
Is lemon curd something that
they have in France
-or is it a very British thing?
-[Manon] Not really, no.
Even, like, ginger cake
is not really a thing that we do.
Have you practised this?
A little bit.
You haven't have you?
This week was quite busy at work
so I'm improvising a little bit.
Just a bit worried that my cake batter's
a bit runnier than normal.
[Noel] The high liquid content
in a ginger cake batter
can make baking times unpredictable.
I should have put 40 millilitres
of milk in with the eggs.
I didn't put any milk in.
I put forty millilitres of, uh, brandy.
Right, here they go.
[Noel] Just a few minutes
can be the difference between
a cake that's deliciously sticky...
One-six-five for 50 minutes.
Low and slow.
...and one that's dense and claggy.
[Ruby] Do your thing.
-[Rahul] Going in for 25 minutes.
-[beeping]
Oops.
[Noel] But the perfect baking time...
What's going on?
...could be the least of Dan's worries.
What the hell is that?
It looks like cheese.
[Noel] Dan's batter has split.
So that's literally
never happened before, ever.
[Noel] Hello, Dan. How's it going?
[Dan] Oh, mate, I am a hot mess.
[Noel] You're a hot mess? Why?
[Dan] I don't know what happened.
I ended up with, like,
lumps of cheese in my cake batter.
Yeah, I know,
I don't understand what the hell happened.
Well, I don't know anything about baking
so I can't help you,
but that doesn't sound good.
Well, I'm assuming
the milk got overheated.
I mean, I don't know how I would have
made curds in my cake batter.
What sort of milk is it? Breast milk?
[Manon] Yum, yum, yum.
That's what lemon curd should look like.
And then I'm gonna
start making the meringue.
[Sandi] Well most of the other bakers
move on...
I'm just making my caramel buttercream.
...Dan has a crucial decision to make.
I'm making brandy
alexander cream cheese frosting.
So, I'm making my jam.
These are dried apricots that have been
soaked in water overnight.
[Dan] I'm gonna have to start again.
I mean, I don't really have any choice.
[sighs]
I'm actually screwed now.
That's half an hour gone
and I'm back to zero.
The curse of the star baker.
[Sandi] But he's not the only baker
who had to get a sponge in the oven.
[singing]
♪ Take good care of me ♪
♪ I don't want your love anymore ♪
I'm making a caramelised
pear and ginger cake.
Like an upside down cake.
I'm just letting the caramel cool in
the tins now with the pears in
and then the batter will then go on top.
[Sandi] Terry's caramelised pears
will sit on top of two ground
and stem ginger sponges,
which will be sandwiched
and decorated with a vanilla cream
and cheese frosting.
[Terry] Batter looks
the right consistency.
It's quite a slow bake, so I need to
get it in the oven
quickly enough, so it can cool
to put the cream cheese on.
[sighs]
Bakers, you are halfway through.
Oh, kill me now.
I wasn't in shot then, was I?
[Terry] Right then, just get those in.
There we go.
[Sandi] Whilst Terry and Dan
finally begin baking...
Right, no cheese this time. [sighs]
Still got so much to do.
...everyone else's dilemma
is when to stop.
Do you smell the ginger? Smells good.
[Sandi] Every minute fresh ginger spends
in the heat of the oven...
[Manon] Okey-dokey.
...it loses flavour.
[Briony] Just so nervous about
undercooking them.
Up. Tac-tac.
[Noel] But stem ginger
will release moisture...
Should be all right.
...which can drastically increase
how long it takes to bake.
It's a bit of a nervy time just
waiting for the cake to come out.
[Karen] Okay, they can come out
and start cooling.
If they're not cool,
you can't get the frosting on
'cause it just melts,
and then it's a mess.
[sighs]
[Sandi]
If that wasn't enough to worry about...
So, we've got the caramel here,
and we've got the pears poaching here,
and I'm making biscuits over here.
Kim-Joy won't just be baking cakes.
[Kim-Joy] It's my little
gingerbread house.
I really like, erm, miniature things.
[Sandi] The smallest gingerbread house
will sit atop crystallised ginger sponge
with cream cheese frosting
and salted caramel drizzle.
[Kim-Joy] Ginger's homely
and it makes me think of being at home.
-[indistinct chatter]
-You can picture yourself in the house,
and there's pears in the background,
and they're kinda like trees. Yeah.
[Noel] For his decoration,
Jon is also thinking of home.
[Jon] Well, they're my kids.
That'll be Hannah and that'll be Lucy.
That's James and Emily.
[Noel] Look at Hannah.
[Jon] There's me.
[Noel] Hello, Hannah.
Oh, I dropped Hannah on her side.
That's the one thing I do know
about children,
don't drop them on their side.
Yeah don't drop them. That's the tip
that is. Don't drop your kids.
-All right, good luck.
-See you later, mate.
I need him at times, don't I?
[Noel] Jon's gingerbread family
will live on top of a stem ginger sponge
with Italian meringue buttercream,
and he's planning to surround
Hannah and the gang
with a touch of bling.
That's my lemon, water and agave solution.
This will be dripped into my oil
to create my lemon tiny balls.
The whole thing sort of forms a jelly,
sort of melts in your mouth.
And I hope they go all right, because
I can't afford for anything to go wrong.
Especially when there could be
two going out this week.
So, no time to relax and have a cup of tea
or anything, you know.
[slurps]
[Sandi] Forty-five minutes remaining.
Come on, cake.
[Karen] I want to get
the dome tops off them,
and then I'm gonna get them
chilled in the fridge.
[Terry] Ah!
They're ready for out.
Ow.
They're going straight in the freezer.
[Ruby] They're not thoroughly cooled,
but I don't want to risk the time.
[Briony] It's important to get it level.
Kinda just gotta get it on as well.
This tiny house. Is that Sandi's house?
-It could be, yeah! [laughs]
-It could be Sandi's house.
[Ruby] Why does he look wonky?
It's gone suddenly very hot in here.
They're still really hot.
-[Sandi] Bakers!
-You have ten minutes remaining.
[Sandi] You can do this.
-We believe in you.
-Some of you.
It's time to get started then, isn't it?
I can't assemble until that's cool.
That's just gonna melt the cream cheese.
No, don't eat... Noel! Did you eat any?
-No.
-[laughs]
Still too hot.
Gonna have to go for it
and put it in the fridge, I think.
Come on.
It's so unstable. It's terrifying.
[breathes deeply]
Bakers, you've got one minute left.
Sixty seconds.
[Terry] It's sliding everywhere. Too hot.
It's gone a bit... [sucks teeth]
Bakers, your time is up.
Please place your ginger cakes
at the end of your workstations.
Oh, I give up.
-That's a proper drip cake.
-That's what we wanna eat.
Look, you're wobbling it. Get off.
You're wobbling the floor.
-What, I want a taste.
-No.
-[Ruby laughs]
-You're wobbling the floor.
Don't, it's seriously.
It's gonna collapse. Don't.
[birds chirping]
[Noel] The bakers' signature ginger cakes
are about to face
spice week's first judging.
-Hi, Jon.
-Hello.
Right, Jon.
[Paul] It's a very concise little cake.
The little balls on the top
look quite good.
[Prue] Nicely executed.
-That's his family you're just mutilating.
-[laughing]
It's a little claggy. A little too...
[clicks tongue]
But the flavour, when you do hit
one of the little lemon gels
is beautiful because you've got
a lovely blend between the two.
[Prue] And they were surprising,
I've never had those little
lemon goldy balls.
-They're so good.
-Ah, cheers.
It's quite a hard cake that.
I put some, erm...
-Oh, Karen.
-No?
[Paul] Too much booze.
[Prue] Too much booze.
Too much booze.
I've never heard Prue say too boozy.
I know. I never thought
I'd hear me say that either.
-Well thank you...
-[Paul] Thank you, Karen.
...for your appraisal of that.
The colours are beautiful.
They look very pretty.
The drizzle looks great as well.
-You get the rum.
-Yeah.
-[Prue] It's delicious.
-Good.
[Paul] The rum is
an overwhelming flavour,
-but it ain't no ginger cake for sure.
-Oh, really?
-[Paul] I think it looks amazing.
-Thank you.
[Paul] Your pipework is very good.
[Prue] It's very pleasing to look at.
It's lovely.
Mmm.
Lovely and gingery. Good texture.
[crunching]
You my friend are a little genius,
aren't ya?
Because you surprise me every week.
Every week,
the sponge is perfect.
The stem ginger is awesome.
[Prue] I mean,
I have never liked honeycomb.
With ginger in it, it's lovely.
You are one hell of a baker. Well done.
[Rahul] Thank you.
-Thank you.
-[Prue] Amazing.
-See, I told ya.
-Thank you.
[Paul] Quite annoying really. [chuckles]
-[Rahul] Sorry?
-[chuckles] You've made him angry.
-Why?
-Said it was too good.
Sorry.
[Paul] It looks quite impressive.
It's a lovely looking cake.
[Prue] Nice shiny chocolate.
[Prue] It's very dry.
[Briony] Oh...
It didn't taste very gingery
or very sweet.
[Paul] The apricot tends to overwhelm it.
To be honest, apricot and the ginger
together doesn't necessarily work.
Okay.
[Paul] It looks a mess.
I think it is down to
the temperature of the cake.
Interesting texture.
[Prue] It's very gluey.
And the ginger's not overwhelming either.
It's definitely a winter one
with loads of custard for sure.
Which ironically is what it looks like.
[laughing] Yeah, it is.
[Paul] The gingerbread house
looks incredible.
The attention to detail looks fantastic.
That is the most beautiful textured cake.
-Ah.
-[Paul] The flavour
from the ginger in the powder
is beautifully balanced
and it's got a nice warmth
that comes through.
That is, erm...
It's, erm...
[Paul] ...beautiful.
-Ah. Thank you.
-[Prue] Well done, Kim.
[bakers clapping]
[Kim-Joy] Got such sweaty hands.
[chuckles]
-Thank you so much. Thank you.
-[Prue] Well done Kim-Joy. Wonderful.
Obviously, there's
an issue to the lean.
[Dan] Yep.
[Prue] Leaning tower of ginger.
[Paul] But I think it comes down to timing
because the sponge is probably
still too warm.
It's gone more and more condensed.
So as you start at the top it's lighter,
slightly less so, slightly more dense...
[Prue] And very.
[Paul] ...and then dense.
It's such a pity because being too warm
when you were putting it together
has affected everything.
[Paul] Very elegant looking cake.
[Prue] Very elegant.
And a little touch of chocolate.
-Again, you blowtorched it.
-[Prue] Nicely done.
Ooh, it got a bit all together.
[Paul] Such a rich colour in there.
Mmm...
Certainly, get the ginger and the lemon.
It's so beautiful how soft the sponge is.
And because the lemon curd is so strong,
-the Italian meringue makes it less so.
-Mmm-hmm.
Yeah, it's one of the best ginger cakes
I've had for some time.
-[gasps] Yay! [chuckling]
-[all clapping]
Thank you. Can I have one Prue, too?
That actually reminds me of my nan's cake,
which is full of ginger,
but it's the bake. It's so good.
Thank you so much. Thank you.
Great job, Manon.
So happy. Got a handshake.
And a Prue pat as well.
[whispers] Kim-Joy.
I got a handshake.
In my head I was like,
"This is really cool.
I hope they think it's cool."
And they thought it was cool.
-Are you happy?
-Yeah, yeah. I'm trying.
You're just "trying"? [chuckles]
I'll probably give the recipe to my mum
so that she can make it.
I'm not sure
whether they will like it or not.
You don't want it to look like
you don't know what you're doing.
I just need to be safe.
There's no reason why
I can't still be safe.
[Sandi] Spice week's technical challenge
is twice as mysterious as
any of the bakers have faced before.
We've got this.
Now, your technical challenge today
has been set for you by Paul.
Paul, any words of advice or wisdom?
This challenge is
all about delicate baking.
That can't be it.
-That's it.
-[Sandi] Okay.
As ever it's judged blind
so I'm gonna ask you two lovelies
to leave the tent.
They're gonna go and play Fortnite.
-What?
-It's an online survival game.
It's not going well.
Prue keeps killing Paul.
Oh, okay.
Anyway, for your technical challenge,
Paul would like you to make
two batches of six maamoul.
[Noel] Come again?
Maamoul, you know, the delicious
ancient pastries from the Middle East.
One batch must be filled with
walnuts and shaped with a mould.
The other batch must be filled
with a date paste
and must be decorated
by pinching the dough
with maamoul tongs.
[Sandi] There you go.
Never before have I known less
about what I'm saying right now.
[all laugh]
You've got an hour-and-a-half.
On your marks...
-Get set...
-Bake.
[Karen] Maamoul. Maamoul.
Maamoul. Maamoul.
I don't know what a maamoul is.
[Briony] No idea what they look like.
No idea what they taste like.
So whatever I make,
I'll be happy with. I hope.
Paul, I'm really ashamed to say
that I have never heard of maamoul.
What are they?
[Paul] Traditionally,
it's Middle Eastern pastry
eaten at the end of Ramadan
and it's really celebratory.
So you have two different types here.
You have the date. You have the walnut.
[Prue] They're so beautiful.
So, we've got some pretty punchy flavours
going on inside these.
We have mastic, basically a resin
and it smells a little bit like aniseed.
Now this is mahlab. This is a seed
that sits inside the cherry kernel,
but as soon as you grind them down,
this becomes a very potent flavour.
It's quite like almonds
and cherries at once.
[Paul] Yes. These two spices
are in the pastry itself.
[Prue] It sounds wonderful.
[Paul] The tricky part is, actually,
you want definition on the pastry.
Now, over handle it,
it becomes too rubbery,
becomes too oily and you're gonna lose it.
If we start with the walnut...
-It's really lovely.
-It's very, very delicate.
That's the orange blossom
and the cardamom.
But in the date one,
it's a little bit more pungent.
You've got cinnamon in there,
you have rosewater in there.
So, there is so many big, big flavours
they've gotta be careful of...
Are we telling the bakers
how much to put in?
We are for the dough,
but not for the filling.
-You are unkind, Paul.
-[both chuckle]
[Briony] So we've got, for the dough,
put the mastic in a mortar
with one teaspoon of the sugar
and grind to a powder.
[Kim-Joy] I've never cooked
with mastic before.
I don't really know what it tastes like.
[Dan] Well, I've come across mastic.
It's an ingredient in tsoureki,
the Greek bread.
Combine with the remaining
dry ingredients.
Add the ghee and rub together
to form a breadcrumb consistency.
Tablespoon of orange blossom.
Tablespoon of rosewater.
Exactamundo, in there.
And then knead until smooth.
Oh, very, very crumbly.
[Dan] What does it look like?
-What, the thing?
-Yeah, what is it...
-I have no idea.
-What does it look like?
I'll tell you, at no point
did Noel and I know what we were saying.
-There's no point.
-So you don't know either? No. Okay.
No, I've absolutely...
I'm looking forward to seeing them.
Okay. Jolly good.
So the recipe says knead
until smooth. I've kneaded.
It's pretty smooth.
So I'm now gonna make the date filling.
Rosewater. Ground cinnamon. Mahlab.
There's no, like, quantities.
-It's a guessing game.
-Quite fun.
-That's the mahlab.
-Do--
-Wow.
-[Ruby] How much do I add in?
I'll start little and then add.
Don't want to overload it.
I'm putting one quarter of a teaspoon.
It doesn't say how much rosewater.
It's very fragrant.
[sniffs] It doesn't smell unpleasant.
-Quite nice.
-Middle Eastern food,
it's to do with the softness.
It's not fire cracking.
It's got a lot of rose in it.
I'm gonna put some more spices in there.
[Noel] But the date and mahlab filling
is only half the story.
Walnuts, hello, where are you? There.
Walnuts. Golden raisins. Orange blossom.
Honey. And some ground cardamom.
It's a funny flavour, cardamom.
It can overpower things.
It'll be fine. I'm tasting it
as I'm making the filling.
Wow. How perfect.
You're back to make maamoul.
-Just the thing you were hoping for.
-Yeah, just what I was dreaming of.
[Sandi] I know what I want,
ancient pastry from the Middle East.
That's the one for me.
That's much better.
[Sandi] Bakers, you have
one hour left to finish your maamoul.
[Terry] Flatten each ball of dough
in the palm of your hand
to form a little cup.
Right.
[Briony] So crumbly though this pastry,
so it kind of just falls
apart in your hands.
"Fill six of the pastry cups
with a ball of the date filling
and the remaining six pastry cups
with a ball
of the walnut filling and seal."
Interesting.
And by interesting, I mean awful.
[Ruby] Is that sealed?
-Hello.
-How you doing?
Look at your stance.
I'm loving this. It's like...
What you trying to do,
put a walnut in your casing?
-I have no idea.
-[both chuckle]
[Terry] Ah. That's why
you don't handle it long.
The ghee becomes wet again.
"To shape,
press the walnut filled balls
into the flower shaped mould."
-Eh...
-These are definitely walnut.
So these need to go
in the flower shaped mould.
Seems like a terrible idea, but all right.
So, I guess... Date filling.
That's the date filling.
Please work.
Oh!
Trying to get it out of the mould,
but I can't get it out.
There you go.
Oh, love, yours looks really tidy.
[Ruby] They do look nice.
I'm happy with these.
Oh!
That doesn't work.
Guess what?
I've done the wrong thing
in the wrong mould.
-Can't do anything about that now.
-You can't do it. Don't worry. Just...
Ha. Whoo-oo.
-...crack on.
-Unbelievable.
-[Ruby] Crack on.
-How did I do that?
"For the date filling, shape
the remaining six pastries into balls.
Use the maamoul tongs..."
-What are they?
-Hello.
Oh, hello. You have your maamoul tongs.
Tiny robot arms clapping.
[mimics static noise]
-Hey, Briony's made a cake.
-Yes. [chuckles]
[Jon] "Pinch the pastry
to create six identical designs."
Really don't know
what I'm looking for here.
It says, do a ball.
I think I'm just gonna go with this.
-[Rahul] Something like that.
-It's just a really short pastry.
[Ruby] Very delicate.
Hopefully the impression will stay in
when it's baked.
Bakers, you've got half an hour left.
-That was very good. Quick.
-I know.
Going in.
Okay, I'm just going to put it in.
And now you just hope for the best.
It's more like biscuit
than pastry, really,
so I don't think it will take too long.
I'll check on them in ten minutes.
[oven beeps]
Erm, 20 minutes.
If you need me, I'll be down here.
The problem is, I don't know
what I'm looking for.
I'm going to open my oven.
[Karen] They look beautiful.
This ones are opening.
Who blimmin' knows?
I might put it a tiny bit more.
You don't want them to be dark.
It looks like the pastry's
actually melting.
Know what, I might take mine out.
I've increased the temperature.
They really don't look any different from,
like, when you put them in.
They've got to cool though, haven't they?
I think they're gonna have to
come out, you know.
They're coming out no matter what.
Oh, my goodness me.
They've melted.
-[Karen] It's a disaster this.
-These look terrible.
[Kim-Joy] I just wish the design
was a bit better.
Gonna be taking it out in one minute.
That's it.
Whatever happens, happens.
Er, how long we got left?
Bakers, you have one minute remaining.
[Terry] Er, these are gonna
have to come out.
What a mess.
[Karen] Oh, dear.
Bakers, your time is up.
Rubbish.
That's so disappointing.
My fault entirely.
Please bring your maamouls and place them
behind your photo on the table.
[Dan] I made maamouley.
Does anyone want any?
[both laughing]
[Sandi] Paul and Prue are looking
for 12 beautifully baked pastries
with the perfect balance of spices.
Six filled with date. Six with walnut.
But as they judge,
they have no idea which bakers
have made which maamouls.
[exhales]
[Paul] Right, we'll start down here.
The walnut, they have split.
You can see
some of the filling coming through.
Although the bake looks okay.
It's quite potent.
-Too potent?
-Yeah.
Yeah. Right, let's have
a look at the date.
Slightly deflated maamouls. [chuckles]
[Prue] Doesn't taste of dates.
That spice, it's too strong.
Think they've gone slightly
overboard there with the flavours.
Moving onto number two.
Not much decoration on the date one again.
[Prue] It's more like a flat biscuit
than a ball.
[Paul] Okay.
I like the pastry.
-The bitterness, is that the--
-[both] Mastica.
-Bit, too much.
-[Paul] Yeah.
This has had serious,
serious problems with the pastry.
Just fallen to pieces.
I think it got too hot
and the oil came out.
[Paul] But there's
no definition in this at all.
That's poor pastry.
[Prue] Nice flavour though.
[Paul] Okay, now moving on.
[Prue] There's no pattern on this.
[Paul] Not much filling either is there.
[Prue] Hmm...
-It's nice. Delicious.
-[Paul] It's good that.
There is definition on this one.
-[Prue] There is.
-You can see it on the walnut
and you can see all the ridges.
That's quite well baked.
Can you get that floral hint
coming from the rosewater?
I think that's pretty good.
Now, obviously you can see
the filling coming through in this,
and this is meant to be the walnut one.
They got the wrong shape.
[sniffs]
It is a little overbaked.
It's quite dry, isn't it?
Yeah, wrong shape, very dry,
filling coming through.
Right, a little bit of
definition here. Neat.
Icing sugar on all of them.
You're only meant to ice the walnut one.
[Paul] Pastry and the flavours are good.
Quite delicate the spices...
-Yeah.
-...they're not so potent.
[Paul] And even then, again,
fairly uniform.
Just a shame none of them have got
the real shape on the top.
Start with the walnut. Buttery pastry.
I love that filling.
It's almost toffee like.
[Paul] Right, moving on to the last one.
There is a nice definition
actually in the walnut one
where you see the little flower
coming through on the top.
-Flavour's good. Pastry's good.
-Mmm.
Mmm. Very good filling.
[Paul] Mmm.
[Noel] Paul and Prue
must now rank the maamouls
from worst to best.
Okay, in ninth place is this one.
Whose is this?
Me.
Karen, they're the wrong way round.
Yeah.
In eighth place, we have this one.
Oh, Terry. A bit of a mess, weren't they?
I must have put too much ghee in
because the pastry melted off them.
[Sandi] Jon is seventh. Briony is sixth.
Manon fifth.
And in fourth place, Kim-Joy.
In third spot is this one. Rahul.
Not bad at all.
You did have some definition
on the walnut ones,
but it just comes down to neatness.
And then we have in second place,
this one.
Dan. Quite good definition,
but not on all of them,
but the flavour was fantastic.
So, in first place...
[cheering and laughing]
Me?
The pastry and the flavours together
were very good. Well done.
-Thank you.
-Well done, Ruby.
[Manon] So good at this.
I mean, what?
I mean... I just... what?
Happy days 'cause
the signature was, like, a shocker.
So, yeah, yeah, relieved 'cause I feel
that sort of pulled me back to the middle.
[Jon] Not happy about that one.
Just thought it's spice week,
let's go for it and I killed it.
[Terry] I didn't come last.
I think I should have come last.
Yeah, that was just a disaster.
They looked so... Well everything
felt right until they went in the oven.
[Karen] To pull anything back from this,
I've gotta have a corking,
great showstopper tomorrow.
[Noel] One spice week challenge remains
and the bakers face
a day in the tent like no other.
So our lovely Prudence
under the weather this morning.
I'm gonna blame those spices yesterday.
You seem fine though.
I've got a constitution of a rhino.
Yeah, uh, she's a bit
under the weather today
so I'll be flying solo.
What you looking
at the moment for star baker
is Rahul, Manon, Kim-Joy.
And I would also have
to put Ruby in there,
mainly because she won the technical.
There are two people
who are in very precarious positions,
Karen and Terry.
Briony has to be
introduced to that as well.
Dan and Jon, at the moment,
are very much in the middle,
but having a bad day today,
would naturally bring them down
to the bottom
and put them in a little bit of trouble.
-God, you're handsome.
-I was just thinking that.
-Yeah.
-I'm on the turn. You, too.
We're both on the turn now.
Morning, bakers, and welcome to your
showstopper challenge.
Now, unfortunately, Prue
is not with us this morning,
but that doesn't mean
it's going to be any easier for you.
-Now it's just bad cop, bad cop.
-Yeah.
[bakers laughing]
Paul would like you to make
a spiced biscuit chandelier.
It must be breathtakingly beautiful,
deliciously fragrant,
edible spiced biscuit structure
that can be hung
as a centrepiece over a table.
The flavour and type of biscuit
is entirely up to you.
[Noel] You have four hours.
[Sandi] On your marks...
-Get set...
-Bake.
Oh, it does make me nervous
that it's just Paul judging today. Yeah.
[Sandi] This is the grandest challenge
of the competition so far.
The bakers must perfect huge batches
of deliciously spiced biscuits...
Er, ground cinnamon.
...plus design spectacular structures
strong enough to hang them from.
[Paul] We've had
biscuit challenges before.
I've seen the Coliseum in biscuit,
but this is slightly different.
They're all built from the bottom up.
We're asking for something
to be built from the top down.
This is slightly unusual.
This is all about spiced biscuit
and there's loads
of things they could use
Cardamom, cinnamon, nutmeg.
You want that gorgeous feeling of warmth
that comes from the spice.
Now although the chandelier
has got to be pretty robust,
if they over bake, it's gonna be too hard.
Or if they underbake their biscuit,
chances are it's gonna collapse.
Could be making upwards of
50, 60, 100 biscuits.
So again, consistency throughout all
and perfection, obviously.
[all] Good morning.
Right, tell us all about your
biscuit chandelier, what're you doing?
The spices are possibly controversial,
liquorice and cardamom.
I love liquorice.
[Noel] Karen's future in the competition
rests on her highly unusual
liquorice and cardamom biscuits,
which will be hung in tribute
to her old school friends
back in her home town.
Pontefract's is where, traditionally,
we've grown liquorice
and I went to a Pontefract Girls school.
The uniform was brown.
We used to be called
the Brown Knicker Girls.
-The Brown Knicker Girls?
-I think that's too much information.
[all laugh]
Is that because of the liquorice?
[Sandi] Whichever spice they've chosen,
the balance of ingredients
in their biscuit dough
could ruin the bakers' chances
in this final challenge.
It's not the easiest thing to
make biscuits hang, funnily enough.
[Noel] Too much butter and the biscuits
may crumble before they can be held.
[Manon] I think it's quite sticky.
[Noel] Too much sugar
and they'll be so brittle,
the components
of their chandeliers will crack,
destroying their showstoppers.
I'm putting marshmallow
and things in there.
I think I can afford to go
a little bit more crispy on the biscuit.
The main thing is structure on this.
I don't want it falling apart.
[Sandi] Jon's hoping
to pull clear of trouble
with a marshmallow and raspberry
chilli jam filled cinnamon biscuit.
It's his second family themed bake
of spice week.
For my daughter's 21st birthday--
So, I thought I would do this for her.
She loves cinnamon.
[Sandi] Jon's daughter won't be
the only one celebrating
with a cinnamon chandelier.
I thought it would be a fun thing to do
for, like, a kid's birthday party.
My daughter will be turning six,
so it's sort of, like, pink and purple
and butterflies and very girly.
[Noel] Constance will celebrate
her sixth birthday
with flying butterfly shaped
cinnamon biscuits,
ornately decorated with apple icing.
Apple itself, you're not gonna
really taste that in an icing.
So, it's made with apple juice,
and I'm boosting it
a little bit with a bit of
out-of-a-bottle.
When you're adding icing it
also effects the texture of the biscuit
and it's gonna be hanging.
It's a ridiculous idea, no offence, Paul.
-Er, but...
-What...
-Hang on a minute, hang on a minute.
-[all laugh]
Are you saying that the challenge itself
is a ridiculous idea?
-I wouldn't start there, Dan.
-If you do an internet search
for biscuit chandelier,
do you know what comes up?
-[Paul] Nothing.
-Nothing.
-[all laugh]
-Exactly. That's why it was chosen.
[humming]
[Noel] Three more bakers are
celebrating a special occasion.
But for their showstoppers,
Christmas has come early.
[Kim-Joy]
I imagine this at a Christmas party,
with people picking off biscuits
as they're chilling and doing whatever.
[Noel] Kim-Joy's bid for
her first star baker crown
has seen her add extra nutmeg and cinnamon
to her Christmas biscuits,
shaped as snowflakes and featuring
intricately iced festive scenes.
[Kim-Joy] Time is the biggest factor.
The hanging biscuits I'm making 28.
So, not too many because I want to
decorate them quite a bit.
Yes.
[Sandi] Manon is also throwing
a Christmas party.
Mine would be like
a Great Gatsby style party.
Er, so I went for, like,
an art deco style.
[Sandi] Her art deco chandelier
will feature chocolate
and tonka bean checkerboards, inspired
by her Christmases back in France.
[Manon] Every year at Christmas,
my mum and dad get this amazing chocolate
from a chocolatier.
And he always uses, like,
so many different spices
and I think it's from there
that I've learnt about tonka.
Yeah, so I went with it.
[Noel] Hoping to avoid leaving the tent...
My dough has become very wet.
...Terry is throwing
the biggest Christmas party he can.
My chandelier is a Christmas chandelier
based on the song
"On the 12 Days of Christmas".
-Okay.
-Characters 12, 11, 10, nine, eight,
seven, down to a partridge
in a pear tree.
That's a lot.
Seventy-eight characters.
You've got your work cut out.
I have, cut out literally with a cut-out.
But, erm, yeah.
[Noel] As well as taking on 12 verses,
Terry's baking two flavours of biscuit,
a cinnamon clove and pepper
and an all spice and vanilla.
And he plans to decorate all 78.
-It's all about timing.
-[Terry] I know.
It really is.
Try and reign it in today Terry.
Yeah. I'm down to... My maids are
milking now. So onto number eight.
It's a great sentence. I'm down to
my maids are milking.
[laughing]
What you doing?
Well, with Prue not here to interpret,
we're gonna have to learn to speak Paul.
Oh, good point. What you got?
Narky, a state of anger and irritation.
Perfect. Bakers, you've had one hour.
You have three hours left.
If baking huge quantities of different
sized biscuits wasn't complicated enough.
[Terry] So, the colour it goes in
initially, it's always dark.
So, it's quite hard to tell and sometimes
they look a little bit burnt.
...the bakers will now have to start
planning the large biscuit structures
that they hope will support them.
So, this is what my dangly bits
will hang off of.
[Sandi] Whilst they can use materials
to strengthen them...
Perspex holds much better
than just plain biscuit.
...they must be invisible
and covered in biscuit.
My sister said,
"You're a trained architect,
like, you should know about
the structure." "Erm, no, love."
[Sandi] Ruby's peacock themed chandelier
will need to support the weight of
50 pistachio and cardamom biscuits,
sandwiched with a thick raspberry
and white chocolate ganache.
My only query is,
because it's fairly warm today...
[Ruby] Quite warm. Yeah.
...and you're using a ganache base,
which is chocolate.
If that softens, it will drop.
Er. I didn't think of that. It'll be fine.
I actually left it hanging overnight
and it was fine.
-Right.
-There you go.
-Where did you do that though?
-At home.
-In a freezer.
-In a freezer. Iceland.
With supports and everything.
[Briony] I hung it up overnight
to see if it would hold
and it did,
so I'm hoping it'll be all right today.
But you never know
'cause in the tent
everything's completely different.
[Noel] Making it to the next round
will mean Briony's structure will support
forty highly decorated biscuits
with mixed spice,
clove and an Eastern kick,
straight from her local coffee shop.
So, I am doing a turmeric latte
biscuit chandelier.
Just when I thought
this couldn't get weirder. Okay.
I know, right. It's a really nice flavour.
It's quite unusual.
And are you ever going to get
the turmeric stains off you?
No. Do you know, what?
I look so ill after I make these.
My mum was like, "Are you all right?"
I'm like, "Yeah, don't worry,
it's just turmeric." [chuckles]
[Rahul]
I hope it's gonna look like a chandelier.
Well, that's the whole plan.
[Sandi] Rahul is also heading East.
Mine is for a Durga Puja party.
It's like a worshipping of this
ultimate Goddess,
Mother Goddess or something.
[Sandi] Rahul will celebrate
the Hindu festival of Durga Puja,
with a structure that must support
six hanging rows
of individually decorated and filled
orange and cardamom biscuits.
How many biscuits?
I'm making about 150 biscuits.
-[Noel] What?
-Yeah. I know, I'm crazy.
-[Paul] 150 biscuits?
-Yeah.
I know I'm crazy.
I'm just going to try my best
-and see as far as I can go.
-Okay. Good luck.
What do you think of the judging?
Oh, nobody will know the difference.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
[Terry] You always think
there's plenty of time
and then there never is.
It just seems to, [vocalizes], evaporate.
Ooh, that needs to come out
the oven, don't it?
[Dan] Yeah, they're done.
That is just starting to colour,
so it's good.
Where am I gonna put it now? Oh, my gosh.
Just need to get those cooled. Damage.
Puffed up a little bit.
They've got, like, a crack along the top,
such a weird thing.
I've lost count. Genuinely lost count
of how many biscuits I've got going on.
Ugh!
[Sandi] This challenge is about to get
even more complicated.
This is the other batch.
[Sandi] With time tight,
the bakers will now have to
start decorating the baked biscuits...
I'll put in some apple juice.
So, I will use some synthetic assistance.
Essence in a bottle.
We'll keep that to a minimum.
...while constantly preparing
and baking even more.
I think that I'm still behind. [sighs]
I just hope I'm doing this
as fast as I would at home.
[Noel] All the icing needs to be set
before the biscuits can be hung...
I'm scared of running out of time
and having nothing decent to show.
...otherwise it will smudge
or even worse, run off the biscuits.
[Dan] This is just like
a classic wet-on-wet technique.
Either they dry in time or they don't.
Time, I'm just concerned now.
Gotta get some decoration on these.
I've still got 21 little biscuits to make.
[Briony] It does actually look like
I've had some sort of psychedelic disco.
They'll look better with decoration,
I promise.
[laughing]
Oh, these are good.
[Rahul] What flavour can you get?
-Cardamom.
-Oh, that's good. And?
I don't even know
what cardamom is. I just said that.
-[Rahul] I know that.
-[Noel laughs]
[Karen] So, this is just to go on the top.
Oh, no.
Just not great.
I'll make this again.
I swear something's burning.
[sniffs]
Oh, I think I might have
burnt my biscuits.
Those are rubbish.
[Noel] Bakers, you've got
half an hour left.
Half an hour to complete
your biscuit chandeliers.
Man that is not a lot of time.
[Manon] Okay. Showtime.
[Sandi] The bakers now have
the terrifying task
of assembling their delicate chandeliers.
It's a case of making sure
that it all hangs equally.
[sighs]
This is just, like, icicle, like drips.
These are gonna have to go up
sooner than I'd like.
[Manon] Oh, God, I'm shaking.
[exhales]
[Jon] Too quiet, you know, it's scary.
I just realised the biscuits are so soft.
[Karen] Such pressure.
Keep going. Keep going. [grunts]
I would have liked longer for decoration,
but I'll get something decorated.
Did you get your maids are milking done?
I did. All my maids are milked.
I don't think you should milk a maid.
-No. Not at this point.
-I don't know. No.
Oh, no. It's just looking rubbish now.
Argh!
[Jon] I don't know what the hell
has gone wrong with these.
The biscuits are breaking
as I'm pushing them down.
[sighs]
[Ruby] I'm just sandwiching the biscuits.
[groans] It's just not thick enough.
The ganache has let me down.
Just wouldn't hold.
Right, not getting sandwiched.
There's nothing else I can do about it.
-Bakers, you have...
-...five minutes left.
Ah!
Just going to be really tight with time.
Turtle-dove broke its neck.
A little girls dream is
a big man's nightmare.
[stutters] Yeah, yeah.
Eight maids milking. We're down to seven.
One's dropped on the floor.
Finishing touches.
[grunts]
[Rahul] This looks so messy.
Four verses to go.
Most of them say Emily.
Oh, that doesn't.
Bottom one's a bit of a mess,
but never mind.
She's on. She's off. She's on.
-Bakers, your time is up.
-[inhales deeply]
Please step away from
your biscuit chandeliers.
[blows raspberry]
They're our biscuit chandeliers
in this room,
-I didn't even think there'd be one.
-[Briony] Yeah, they are.
[Ruby] You're so annoying.
What did I do now?
Come on, Ruby.
-You're so annoyingly good.
-You can't say that to me.
[Sandi] It's judgment time
for the spiced biscuit chandeliers.
Manon, please will you
bring up your showstopper.
Ah, this is a delicate business.
[Noel] What could go wrong?
-[Paul] I think it looks amazing.
-Thank you.
I think the detailing
round the top is very good,
but what's impressive is the fact that
you've given it all the same shade
all the way down.
Now the chequerboard effect...
Did you build it all up
and then chop it--
Yes... Ooh.
[all laugh]
And then--
[Sandi] Oh. Wow, we're under attack.
It's all about the spice for me,
and I'm not getting much in the way of
massive amounts of flavour,
which I would have expected.
But as the biscuit goes and the design,
it's very, very impressive.
[Paul] The pattern
on the butterflies is exquisite.
But what does it taste like?
I don't get any cinnamon in that biscuit.
All the flavour comes from the icing,
which is almost a synthetic flavour
that I'm getting.
[Ruby] They were meant to be sandwiched,
but unfortunately with the heat,
as you suggested, it wouldn't stay.
Pistachio's lost,
but the cardamom in there is delicious
and it's a beautifully baked biscuit.
Thank you.
[Sandi] Rahul, please bring up
your chandelier.
[Noel] Don't drop that, please.
I think what you've done is, is beautiful.
I think the colours are amazing.
You've got the sugar work inside there
as well, which is fantastic.
It's a bit messy in places.
It's almost like time was
against you all the way.
How many biscuits did you make?
A hundred and fifty?
The flavour of that cardamom,
the way it melts in the mouth,
the butter in the biscuit is beautiful.
You've even got
that little bit of blossom,
that little hint at the back as well.
It's a fantastic biscuit.
You need to pull something back
'cause it's nearly there.
It's just a little bit messy in places.
The biscuits look solid, you know, chunky.
-We're big girls in Pontefract.
-[all laugh]
Still are. Sorry.
What's weird is the liquorice
and cardamom together tastes like ginger.
Liquorice is one of those flavours that
has to be quite pure to come through.
I'm curious about the texture
of this biscuit.
It's almost got a skin on the top of it.
[Briony] Yeah, it's kinda cracked, yeah.
Yeah. I've never seen anything like it.
Oh, okay. Well I hope you like it.
Mixed spice, a little bit of clove,
turmeric...
[exhales] Possibly.
It is unusual. I've never had
a biscuit like that before.
Okay.
Kim-Joy, would you like to
bring up your spiced biscuit chandelier.
Well, that is exquisite.
-Aww.
-Your piping is phenomenal.
I mean, these little biscuits
down the bottom.
I mean, look at the detail on that.
It's absolutely gorgeous.
I love the little icicles
with the isomalt as well.
Very, very clever.
Thank you.
The spices you've got in there
really work together.
It's the classic Christmas combination.
Have you got a little bit of
nutmeg in there as well?
Yes, oh, yeah, nutmeg.
It's got a lovely warmth to it.
That is very, very well thought through.
Thank you so much.
That was stunning.
Did you finish it?
-Did you get everything done?
-No. No.
[Paul] The biscuits, look quite dark,
some of them.
This tree at the bottom looks a bit...
-Black.
-Yeah.
Run by the flavours again for me?
Er, cinnamon, mixed all spice
and black pepper.
[Paul chomping]
-It's quite bland.
-Really?
Considering what you put in there,
all the spices and the pepper,
I expected it to be full of flavour
and it just isn't.
Hmm.
The maids here are
a slightly different biscuit.
-Not getting it again.
-No?
I think the idea was very good
and you got a lot of the detail on there,
but I think you took on far too much.
Yeah.
Jon, would you like to bring up
your biscuit chandelier please.
-It's a bit messy.
-It is very.
It feels like it needs finishing off.
As far as the flavour goes,
cinnamon is the king there.
I mean, it is like a shortbread,
such a delicate, buttery biscuit.
If I was blindfolded and ate that,
it would have been fantastic.
-Thank you very much.
-Thank you.
-Cheers.
-[Sandi] Thanks, Jon.
Right, my lovely bakers,
nothing left for you to do
while Paul has to decide
who is the star baker
and who are the two people
who are going to be leaving us this week.
[Briony] That's like, nine down to seven.
It's just such a big jump, you know.
I'd like to think that I did well,
but yeah, I don't know.
Paul's very diplomatic,
a gentleman, I think.
Very kind actually.
[Jon] I can bake better than that.
Hopefully with the flavours
in my biscuits,
it'll keep me through to week six
'cause that's all I'm hoping for
at the moment.
[Karen] Clearly, I'm one of them.
I am going home.
Of course.
[quacking]
You've lost your double act partner.
How was it for you?
I missed Prue, actually, today.
I missed her. There's too
much testosterone at this table.
-What, from you and Paul?
-Yeah.
[Paul and Sandi chuckle]
So the showstopper, has that
shifted things dramatically?
I think when it comes to star baker...
I think, Rahul is in the running.
Again, his biscuit...
Unbelievable...
I mean, it melted in the mouth.
You have to put Kim-Joy
in the mix for star baker
because that showstopper was superb.
Karen and Terry were struggling
a little bit coming into the showstopper.
Still struggling?
[Paul] There was no real
spice coming through.
[Sandi] Briony did quite well.
[Paul] Yeah.
[Sandi] Has she saved herself?
[Paul] It was a strange one.
She used a lot of
different spices, didn't she?
She did and I think,
probably if I'm honest, too many.
I will put Jon in there as well.
It was a bit all over the place
and sort of a bit messy.
As Prue's not here,
did you want our help
'cause we... We can absolutely
help you make your decision?
-No.
-[Sandi] Okay.
That's a no. I think that's a no.
Is that a no?
Well, well done, bakers. That's the end
of the very first ever spice week
and what a fragrant success
you made of it.
This week I have the great job
of announcing
star baker and it was quite tight.
But the star baker this week is
-Kim-Joy.
-[bakers cheering]
That's so good. Well done.
So proud of you.
So I get the rotten job I'm afraid.
It's a really unusual week,
we are sending home two people.
And the two people
who will be leaving the tent...
Are Karen and Terry.
Oh, well. That's all right. No problem.
-[Ruby] Sorry, love.
-That's all right.
[sighs]
[Sandi] It was great.
You got halfway through.
What a crazy, crazy few weeks
I've had here. [exhales]
Yeah.
-Outside of having your family...
-[Noel] It's not right you're going.
...as a personal achievement,
nothing will ever top this,
I don't think, obviously.
-You've done really well, mate.
-Well, no, you're a gentleman.
[sniffles] I said I wouldn't get upset.
Erm...
It's funny when you're on your own...
Thank you, Dan. Good luck.
My wife and I were very happy,
and that was a massive loss,
and there wasn't anything that filled
that void for a long time.
So, it did give me a focus.
-I shall miss you.
-Gonna miss you. I'll miss you.
Thank you so much.
-[Terry] I've met some lovely people.
-It's all right.
I'm sure we'll keep in touch
for a long time.
Yeah, it's been a big help...
[clears throat] Sorry.
It's been a big help
and, erm...
One I'll remember for a long time.
-I'm gonna miss you.
-Ah! I'll miss you too.
[Terry] I won't stop baking.
I'm very much looking forward to
more adventurous projects
carried out in a bigger time-frame.
No baking for a bit.
I'm going away in the caravan.
Well done, Kim-Joy.
You did well. You did well.
I'm so happy.
I was hoping, hoping, hoping
and it happened,
and I'm over the moon.
It's not the week
that I expect it to happen,
spice week, when my flavours
have been a bit... Mmm...
But it makes me feel like
I've learnt things.
It's so nice but then I feel like,
"Oh, maybe, the pressure's on
for next week
and I'm gonna have to practice a lot."
[theme music playing]